camjac faisant est venu il a appris à
lino ventura à faire la caricature de
monsieur marché nous l'avait très bien
fait il l'a très bien fait
et puis lorsque gus est venu il a fait
une caricature du présentateur
d'émissions qui était pas mal non plus
j'ai trouvé très très bien que je
regarde tous les jours maintenant ça me
donne l'impression de me regarder dans
la glace
alors je sais pas ce que vous avez
décidé de fermer vous avez quand même le
droit d'utiliser le matériel
professionnel qui est le vôtre monsieur
cabut on va vous apporter sa voix tout
est là
cabu a décidé de me donner une leçon que
je vais prendre volontiers alors qu'on
redémarre à zéro à la première leçon en
dessin pour présenter une figure humaine
il suffit de dessiner une ampoule
essayer de dessiner une ampoule cette
journée c'est pour dessiner quelqu'un de
connu bon vous allez voir
pour faire cette caricature il faut
commencer par désigner une ampoule
pour moi c'est bien mais pierre qu'on
voit bien voilà c'est bien c'est
exactement ça il manque quelques petits
détails vous allez voir
on rajoute un cul de poule la puisaye eh
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai qu'il suffit
de l'an poule pour faire le président un
jeu pas qui on dit bravo
deuxième leçon
deuxième leçon monsieur cabu ya le
premier ministre voulait vous dessinez
un un cercle un rond doucement et projet
voilà au milieu d'eux seront tracés un
plus petit rond qui fera le nez il ya la
tempête ce soir là
ça va en fait de deux parenthèses là
pour marquer les yeux le nez deux
peuples et deux jours oui et là vous
faites une bouche comme ça comme une
comme une vague comme un oiseau voilà
c'est vrai que ça commence à lui
ressembler les pattes la lune tout de
suite c'est alors attendez
erreur
le premier écope pour dessiner coluche
vous allez voir c'est une première étape
pour dessiner coluche si vous voulez
dessinée coluche vous commencé par
dessiner raymond barre sérieux vous
rajoutez un peu de cheveux
si vous avez un crayon rouge ou ou
rajouter un peu de rouge sur le nez et
voilà
encore un onzième le son soit 8,3 à
présent monsieur tchernia vous allez
dessiner une sorte de grand corbeau qui
s'envolent comme ça à la vérité il faut
dire que il faut dire que cabu m'a fait
répéter parce que sinon ça absolument
incapable de bien alors également une
espèce de corbeau il dit et c'est pas
mal non me faudra couvrir montage parce
que c'est un peu long il faudrait faire
un plan de coupe sur véronique par
exemple sur villers jour que pierre
bureau n'est pas de problème
comprenez pas c'est ça ce qu'on appelle
un plan de coupe au magnétoscope paf il
passe sur véronique et puis quand on
revient sur moi des sacs et il parle de
sa main en tout cas mon corbeau est
terminée ou lors qu'est ce que c'est
noir en donc floue voilà il est très
bien alors si vous voulez faire le nez
qui arrive à la hauteur de la bouche les
cheveux tout ce que vous voulez
doucement
signer quand ils étaient petits seins ça
se voit il dessine bien alors maintenant
on va en voir à quoi ça ressemble
c'est fou alors là c'est de funès là
d'accord c'est la première étape pour
dessiner
alain peyrefitte vous allez voir il faut
passer par de funès pour retrouver alain
peyrefitte moi c'est pas évident les cas
vous allez voir vous rajoutez quelques
cheveux peut-être que pourrait faire
quelque chose pour les oreilles
voilà et vous doublez oreilles et vous
avez peyrefitte